la file d'attenté en disait long sur
l'intérêt pour la comparution du numéro
1 de facebook devant le sénat américain
pour quelqu'un qui n'est ni les
projecteurs ni les caméras
mark zuckerberg aurait été servis face à
ce jeune loup milliardaire de 33 ans
quelques vieux renard de la politique un
véritable choc des générations avec
parfois de la confusion sur la
compréhension du dossier
watsa l'impassible face au long
réquisitoire des sénateurs zuckerberg a
de nouveau servi son mea culpa
oui mais le sénat voulait surtout des
réponses maîtres facebook sur la
sellette avec le danger du partage de
données personnelles et pour l'illustrer
la question de ce sénateur serait il
prêt à donner le nom de son hôtel ah non
quant au présumé consentement des
utilisateurs de facebook
il est bien trop volumineux et compliqué
selon ce républicain et puis ce fameux
modèle d'affaires de facebook qui est
encore gratuit
comment est ce possible sa rivale à la
publicité
évidemment ciblées qui est au coeur du
problème auquel fait face facebook alors
la solution passe-t-elle par une
réglementation contraignante de son
industrie dès le 25 mai la protection
des données personnelles sera renforcée
en europe et facebook devrait notamment
obtenir un consentement claire et plus
précis des utilisateurs sans quoi il y
aura des sanctions à la loi européenne
est quand même intéressant parce qu'elle
a des dents on parle s'il ya des
pénalités a donné ça pour aller jusqu'à
4 % des profits de l'entreprise dans
l'année dans le code d'un grand joueur
comme facebook google ou apple
c'est une fortune qui tomberait dans les
mains d argent mais le congrès américain
ira-t-il jusque là avec un congrès
actuellement aux mains des républicains
de trump un président qui justement des
réglemente rien n'est moins sûr ici
frédéric arnould radio canada montréal